i'm jane secker
and you're listening to episode 4 of
storycast
21. in 2016 more than 5 000
migrants drowned in the mediterranean as
they tried to reach
europe among the 360 000 people who
attempted the crossing that year
in the biggest mass movement of people
since world war
ii was a family fleeing the war
in syria this is migrant rescue
my name's mark stone and i'm a reporter
a correspondent for sky news
it was january the 15th 2016.
i was in my house in brussels in belgium
just put our son to bed and i was
getting ready for what i thought would
be an uneventful evening
they started as they do every morning
here
looking for the dots on the horizon
some of the tiny migrant boats show up
on radar
some don't we're about five to eight
i got a uh a facebook message
and it was from a young man called basil
shakarni
he says hello mr stone and then there's
a long list of numbers
i told him now my family in this
location
do you have any information about the
weather there
he was in germany messaging me and i
immediately realized what's happening
this is his family who are on the coast
of
of turkey and they were trying to get to
a very small island called nera a greek
island and it's a distance
of around about eight miles so not very
far
but remember it's january the water's
cold and pretty rough
my name is zanzon khalid i'm 28 years
old
i come from syria
i was with basil's family his father
mother and twin sister they
show us the small light in the other
side of a greek island
and told us it's about one hour from
here
my wife and we talked to each other
many times at this day
i said to him the weather is too bad
i'm not sure that we can arrive safe and
my
goods feeling told me that something
will go wrong but we have no other
chance we are
required to do the journey now
i asked mark about the weather and he
told me
it's too risky they shouldn't go
[Music]
well these are the latest pictures
coming in now from russia in hungary
as you're just about to see police there
have been using
tear gas against vassal was a young guy
from the syrian capital damascus
he had been in the military at one point
uh he didn't want to be part of the
civil war in syria
and so he he left
i met him a few months earlier
in budapest in hungary
budapest at that time in late 2015 had
become
a bottleneck in in a migrant route that
was um
crossing europe the hundreds thousands
of migrants make their way
through a variety of countries and to
germany we saw that the spray
of tears bangla merkel the german
chancellor had made a
decision to open germany's borders and
to allow refugees to come in
another spray two sprays of the tear gas
into the faces this was a period of time
when hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of people were
trying to make the journey
either across the aegean from turkey to
greece or across the
mediterranean from north africa to italy
massive challenge for the team now is
trying to make sure that everyone stays
seated
the previous year 2015 at least 3
700 people had died trying to cross
those waters
into europe so i knew
not just from the figures but from
having reported and covered
many other shipwrecks over the months
before
i knew how dangerous this crossing was
slowly the main rescue ship is
maneuvered towards the dinghy
he had told me that his twin sister his
fiancee at the time and his his parents
they would try and join him
in germany once he had managed to put
down some roots
it was about eight or seven o'clock
local time
we were about more than 40 persons
many families with many children
and just we shocked when we saw the boat
even it was difficult to see it
but they turned on light for short time
to check the
engine it might be
just for 10 people maximum
so the wind was strong and very cold
this wind created the huge waves
and the sounds of these waves you can
compare it to the sounds of the
airstrikes
that we heard in syria
i thought of my parents basel
my brothers my sister
and i think could i meet them again or
not
my wife started to send me the location
after one hour i used my laptop to make
a
line of locations
so i noticed that the direction
not to go to the greeks island
brothers they go in the wrong way
by the time this the next exchange of
messages came in it was
20 past 10 in brussels i by this stage
was in bed
he sent me a another set of coordinates
i copied and pasted the long number
into google maps and then this
pin dropped on just a blue screen
and i i pulled out uh on the phone
it was clear then as the screen got
wider that they were in the middle of
the aegean
my wife told me the only light
on these greeks island that we saw
now far away from us
so i told my wife tell this
driver to find the right way
otherwise you will you will not
reach this island
[Music]
i told him how bad the situation is
we see nothing just hear people crying
and
praying to god to help us i told him
about the water
that started to enter into the boat
it was so icy
another set of numbers came in and basil
said now they are here
they ask me to bring help
[Music]
and i replied that i had i had asked for
help
and the reason i was able to do that is
because i had contacts
in the area an organization called moas
who are effectively a um a private coast
guard
on the greek islands and say look i know
there's a boat out there
these are the coordinates what can you
do
so mark told me they have a ship
near of samus and it's not far away from
the location of your family
i was very worried because they are
in the middle of the sea maybe
they will lost the connection or
the mobile phone will get some more
water and
they will be damaged
her mobile phone was the only estimate
that they can use to tell us
about their location to tell us about
the whole situation
and just we had blessing in discuss
because the internet connection was so
good to still communicate
with my husband and send him our
locations
and then basil was sending me more and
more coordinates
and then he says the water level is
raised and they're afraid from the fuel
running out
the driver told us to throw every
luggage we brought with us
in the sea he tried to
decrease the load it was kind of a race
against time
me sending the coordinates to moas moa
saying yep we've got them we're trying
to get there
and then basil sending me more and more
messages which which as i say got more
and more distraught
[Music]
my wife was next to me and wondering why
i was furiously texting
and actually helping to coordinate a
rescue that was taking place
you know a thousand or so miles to the
south
remember it's pitch black they are
looking for a tiny dot on a dark horizon
every minute was for us like a day
in this case you just think whether the
boat
will still be able to bring us
to our destination we'd pass the
coordinates to moas
and within the space of i guess it was
probably 45 minutes or so
[Music]
i was getting messages back saying
they've seen a boat
when we saw the lights of the ship all
of us
turned on the church of our mobile
phones to trying
to make a visible signal that let the
people
on the ship see us quickly
we are there we are here to save you say
if you will we need to stay calm
and stay seated everybody sit down by
this stage the messages
the pings are near constant back and
forth
it's still late at night overcrowded
boat panicking people
the chances of that boat overturning
were quite high and that can happen even
when the rescue boat is closed
[Music]
at this time i was worried because my
mother and my father was so sick
so i tried to call her to send her a
message but
they my messages
weren't arrived
[Music]
i got an email from jason florio the
photographer on board the
rescue boat and it just said hi mark
all safe aboard mohawk's ship the
responder
cheers jason i screen grabbed that
email and sent it straight to basil
eventually uh within within
i guess about another half an hour we
managed to get the uh the lines of
communication
turn them into phone calls and he spoke
to his family on board the rescue boat
[Music]
uh one of the rescuers offered us his
mobile phone i
called my husband basil i said to him we
are alive
we are safe i will never ever do
something like that again
when i hear her voice it's really
was like a miracle
it was a few weeks later in early
february 2016
they were finally reunited in germany
we were on the station platform in
sarbrooken
on the platform basil waits for a train
that's late
but eventually pulls in and on the train
was his mother his father beyonce zane
and his twin sister
it was a wonderful moment actually
seeing this this family reunited after
months
there were moments clearly when basil
thought his family wouldn't make it
this isn't a one-off across europe
dislocated families are being reunited
the elderly it was in the middle of
night
and he left everything and he just sat
on his computer
get these messages for me and sent
them to to his contacts
i'd covered the refugee crisis for many
many months
and for me it was really important to
to individualize these journeys
it puts it all into a better context
zane and basil are now um living happily
in germany they were engaged
when all this took place now they're
married they've got two children
[Music]
the crossing of the mediterranean made
by zayn
is a journey migrants continue to
undertake in 2021.
migrant rescue was written and produced
by robert mulhern
for more information on this podcast go
to skynews.com
forward slash storycast 21.
next time
[Music]
we're in chile where a team of miners
find themselves trapped
more than half a mile underground in the
desert
we were just doing some job and suddenly
just a huge huge amounts of rocks like a
really huge amount of rock
coming down and we tried to run we said
that that's about it we're dead